BUT FIRST, BLOOMY DOESN’T GET
YOUR GUNS.
THAT’S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
"ANGLE"."
JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO, ANTI-DUMB
DEMOCRATS IN VIRGINIA THOUGHT
THEY COULD RAM THROUGH A NEW BAN
ON SO-CALLED ASSAULT WEAPONS AND
HIGH-CAPACITY MAGAZINES.
AFTER ALL, NOVEMBER, THEY WON
CONTROL OF BOTH HOUSES OF THE
STATE LEGISLATURE.
FIRST TIME IN 20 YEARS.
AND GOVERNOR RALPH NORTHAM WAS
AFFORDING THIS BILL, OF COURSE
THE PHONY ARGUMENT THAT ROLLING
BACK THE GUN RIGHTS OF
LAW-ABIDING VIRGINIANS WOULD
MAKE ALL VIRGINIANS SAFER.
>> THIS ISSUE GENERATES GREAT
EMOTIONS, BUT THE FACTS ARE THE
FACTS.
GUN VIOLENCE TAKES THE LIVES OF
MORE THAN 1,000 VIRGINIANS EVERY
YEAR.
THREE PEOPLE EVERY DAY.
AT THAT RATE, EVERYONE ON THE
FLOOR OF THIS CHAMBER WOULD BE
GONE BY MARCH.
>> Laura: I LOVE THE DRAMATIC
PAN OF THE CHAMBER BY C-SPAN.
REMEMBER, THIS IS THE BRILLIANT
LOGIC OF THE SAME GUY WHO ARGUED
THAT INFANTICIDE IS BASICALLY A
HUMAN RIGHT.
THIS WAS ALL HIS ATTEMPT,
KEEPING THE TRAIN OF THOUGHT
THERE, TO KEEP ALL YOU GUN
OWNERS COMFORTABLE.
BUT NORTHAM WASN’T READY FOR THE
PUSHBACK, WAS HE?
THE OPPOSITION MADE SURE THAT
THEIR VOICES WERE GOING TO BE
HEARD, AND BOY WERE THEY HEARD.
YOU KNOW THE DEPLORABLE SCUM OF
THE BITTER CLEANERS?
>> DON’T TARGET THE LAW-ABIDING
CITIZENS.
>> A CITIZEN BORN HERE, YOU’RE A
LOT TO PROTECT YOURSELF.
>> WE ARE NOT GOING TO COMPLY
WITH THEIR GUN-CONTROL.
WE DON’T WANT GUN CONTROL.
>> YOU WILL HAVE A BETTER CHANCE
OF GOING IN A CREEK AND KISSING
A COPPERHEAD THEN YOU WOULD
GETTING GUNS FROM VIRGINIANS.
>> Laura: WELL, WELL, THE
LIBERAL GUN GRAB WENT DOWN IN
FLAMES WITH THE HELP OF FOUR
MODERATES IN NORTHAM’S OWN PARTY
PARTY.
>> IF YOU WENT OUT AND LEGALLY
PURCHASED A WEAPON OR A
PARTICULAR PART, JUST SIMPLY BY
OWNING THAT, YOU COULD BECOME A
CLASS SIX FELONY OR A CLASS ONE
MISDEMEANOR.
IT’S NOT FAIR, IT’S NOT DUE
PROCESS, AND THAT WAS WHAT
REALLY BOTHERED ME THE MOST.
>> Laura: AND IT’S IMPORTANT
TO NOTE THAT THIS GRASSROOTS
UPRISING WAS SUCCESSFUL DESPITE
THE MILLIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
PUMPED INTO THE COMMONWEALTH
FROM OUT OF STATERS, LIKE
DEMOCRAT PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG.
THROUGH HIS GROUP, EVERY TOWN
FOR GUN SAFETY COME HE FUNNELED
$2.5 MILLION IN THE VIRGINIA
LIST MIKE LAST YEAR TO ELECT
ANTI-SECOND AMENDED DEMOCRATS.
EVERY TOWN OUTSPENT THE NATIONAL
RIFLE ASSOCIATION, WHICH IS
BASED IN VIRGINIA, BY A BRIGHT
FACTOR OF: ONE.
MAKING ONE FINAL PUSH FOR THE
GUN BAN.
>> FOR THE FIRST TIME IN MORE
THAN 25 YEARS, VIRGINIA
DEMOCRATS TOOK CONTROL OF BOTH
CHAMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE, AND
I’M HAPPY THAT THEY WON, BUT I’M
EVEN HAPPIER ABOUT WHAT THEY’VE
DONE.
IT’S ONLY BEEN A MONTH SINCE
THEY TOOK OFFICE, AND ALREADY,
YOU’VE TAKEN ACTION TO END OUR
EPIDEMIC OF GUN VIOLENCE.
>> Laura: BY THE WAY, THAT IS
BLOOMBERG SOUNDING PUMPED UP.
THIS IS HOW SOME LOCALS GREETED
HIM.
NOW, SINCE 2014, BLOOMBERG HAD
SPENT $75 MILLION ATTACKING THE
NRA AND YOUR GUN RIGHTS.
AND HE HAS HAD HIS SIGHTS SET ON
VIRGINIA FOR YEARS.
HE HAS THROWN $10 MILLION AT
DEMOCRATS IN THE STATE SINCE
2011.
BUT IT TURNS OUT, THERE IS STILL
A LOT OF JEFFERSONIAN SPIRIT
LEFT IN VIRGINIA.
THEIR SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHTS
AREN’T FOR SALE.
>> HE CAN TAKE HIS MONEY AND HE
CAN KEEP IT IN NEW YORK.
VIRGINIA DOESN’T WANT HIS MONEY.
HE’S ALREADY TRIED TO NEW YORK
VIRGINIA, AND WE ARE DONE.
WE DON’T LIKE IT AT ALL.
AND THAT IS GOING TO HAPPEN
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
>> Laura: I SURE HOPE SO.
BUT BLOOMBERG AND THE REST OF
THE ANTIGUN FORCES IN AMERICA
WON’T LET THIS DEFEAT STOPPED
THEM, NO WAY.
GOVERNOR NORTHAM HAS ALREADY
PROMISED THAT THE GUN BAN IS
GOING TO BE REINTRODUCED NEXT
YEAR.
BUT WHAT HAPPENED IN VIRGINIA
YESTERDAY SHOWS THAT WHEN WE THE
PEOPLE ARGUE THE FACTS AND WE
STAND UNITED FOR A NOBLE CAUSE,
WE CAN OVERCOME THE CORRUPTING
INFLUENCE OF MONEY AND LEFTIST
IDEOLOGY.
BUT IMAGINE IF BLOOMBERG EVER
GOT REAL POWER ON A NATIONAL
LEVEL.
HE LEARNED THE LESSON OF
VIRGINIA.
HE MOVE A LOT MORE SWIFTLY
AGAINST THE SECOND AMENDMENT
RIGHTS OF ALL AMERICANS
BEFORE THE RESISTANCE COULD
ACTUALLY MOBILIZE, AND HE WOULD
SELL IT ALL AS GUN SAFETY
MEASURES.
WHICH TRANSLATED, MEANS YOU HAVE
LESS POWER AND THE GOVERNMENT
MORE.
BUT A LOT OF THOSE BIG, GOLD
DRINKING AMERICANS THAT SHE HAS
SUCH LITTLE RESPECT FOR COMING
OF THE ONES THAT DRIVE PICKUP
TRUCKS AND ACTUALLY MOW THEIR
OWN LAWNS?
THEY ARE ONTO HIS MONEY TRICKS.
A BLOOMBERG NOMINATION IS
GUARANTEED TO DO AT LEAST HURCO
THINGS.
ONE, MOTIVATE THE REPUBLICAN
BASE, AND TWO, DRIVE UP THE